The Joe Rogan Experience you have such a
a knowledge of history and you're so
interested in so many different things
that like it it layers your comedy in a
really cool way thanks it's good it's
like like that George Washington thing I
don't want to say anything because it's
so good yeah I don't want to sound I
don't want to [__] it up but it's so
good I love that bit and it's but it's
also historically accurate it's [__]
fun it's fun because it's like it's in
it's engaging me and it's entertaining
me yeah like it's engaging me it's
interesting and it's also very funny I
always it never worked and I remember it
uh in Lancaster Pennsylvania where like
one of the open mics where I started
Amish Country uh
there was a joke I always used to try my
the guy who was running the mic would
always be like dude do it do the Civil
War joke it never worked it was just
about dudes walking
to shoot each other
like you had to walk it was something
about like uh you know how racist you
had to be to like
be in the South and wake up one day and
be like wait they freed who
what the [__] I'm going up there and
then walking walking the whole way you
had to sleep at night and wake up and go
like son of a [__]
and they walked from Alabama to Maryland
you got shot in the head right away who
had that great joke about that you know
where they'll tell you the Civil War
wasn't about slavery it was about
economics like yeah you didn't want to
pay the help yeah yeah whose joke is I
don't know somebody has that joke I
don't know people try to act like the
Civil War was it Bill Maher maybe it
might be Bill Maher it's someone good
but I always want to do a joke about uh
because they the like your company
whatever your group was because they
were all from the same town yeah so they
would your division or [__] your
Brigade would be from your town
all right so you never left your town so
you were your Brigade back then was
everybody you grew up with every dude
your son your brother your uncle and
your dad you're all [__] together and
you you're marching shoulder to shoulder
and you watch your [__] dad get his
head ripped off by a cannonball you just
gotta keep being like Oh
yeah [__] yeah
you knew who was getting shot oh my God
yeah dude yeah I don't know why that's
fun Imagine
yeah how about the trench warfare of
World War One started in Civil War Siege
of Vicksburg I think that's when they
started training they started yeah they
say the Civil War in America was like
the first modern war
this is the Revolutionary dudes just
getting so horrible look at this walking
towards each other like the stupidest
way to do it ever can you imagine that
people did this for some oh God
oh God
hit in the face with a cannonball now
that's that the Patriots roughly based
off of uh I think his name is Francis
Marion the Swamp Fox
and he was a he was kind of an
originator of Guerrilla warfare because
they were like we can't we can't stand
and fight the British God damn we have
to shoot him and run
which is pretty funny
how crazy are the British just gonna
come over here and start marching yeah
we're gonna walk right out big white
stripe on your chest red red jackets
it's a hundred percent a Target yeah red
and white is what you use for archery
targets
they had to change
them once rifling took over they had to
be like all right we gotta switch our
uniforms isn't that amazing though that
that was that you had to think of how
much the British army conquered in the
world everybody everybody and imagine
that their decision to fight was this
way
like how how did you get from
like the Mongols to that how does that
happen in a thousand years because the
Mongols had all these crazy tactics they
would they would starve people out lock
them in their cities yeah they would
wait them out slowly you get artillery
and guns you can just especially this is
crazy that's just running it down your
throat dude it's like we're gonna walk
at you but
I just can't imagine that someone
wouldn't say hey isn't there a [__]
better way to fight these people yeah
like what do we do let's get behind a
tree and then shoot them I can't even
watch this dude I can't believe people
did that that's what's so crazy it's
like how did they survive to become that
silly
like that's a silly way to fight a war
right so how did they survive with those
strategies how were they dominant with
those strategies they're the only ones
with well most of them are colonies
where the other guys are they have
[__] cow hide Shields and Spears like
the Zulu and so they were the only ones
with monsters [__] guns you just yeah
you're gonna win
you're the only ones with guns so the
British were the only ones with guns
well when it came to like their colonies
on a in a land War they would lose a lot
to like France Prussia
those like major Continental Powers but
England always had a Navy
they always dominated through Naval
Warfare
and then
to team up with everyone to stop
Napoleon dude once they started shooting
cannonballs off boats
that's a problem
when did they start doing that when they
started doing cannonballs from boats
because that's bro that is a
[__] yeah you got a cannon on a
boat shooting people without cannons
boom yeah you just do this all day how
many times did they have to shoot that
Cannon before they figured out how hard
they have to bolt it into the floor
you got a floating wooden thing with
this giant iron tube on it that has
explosions go off on it and just four
guys from Manchester
operating it